i have a clip for you today
that brings together all of the worst of
the american right wing it puts together
conspiracy theories the inability to
accept the
defeat the inability to think critically
the inability to simply push out these
tired republican sycophants that
continue to plague them
and the cherry on top of any good right
wing
conspiracy anti-semitism this this video
clip has it all
newt gingrich former republican
congressman and speaker of the house and
all-around
terrible person went on fox news and
said that joe biden's corrupt election
theft
okay was financed by
people like george soros of course you
have to do it
for any good right wing conspiracy
theory
the money has to have come from the jews
it's almost
a prerequisite here's newt gingrich your
thoughts on that message newt
well look it's it's a nice sentiment uh
first you go out and the
democrats steal five or six states and
that's what republicans believe we're
watching
and we think we have evidence of a lot
of it uh then you turn around and you
say
let's forget four years of nancy pelosi
let's forget four years of impeachment
harassment opposition hostility
hatred and now that i've won why don't
we get nice together
i think he would have to do a lot to
convince republicans
that this is anything except a left-wing
power grab financed by people like
george soros
deeply laid in at the local level and
frankly i
i think that it is a corrupt stolen
election
it's very hard for me to understand how
we're going to work together without
some very very big steps
now newt is right about one thing we're
not going to work together
definitely not with him but how is it
that it's always
one or more rich jews financing the
whole
operation now it's true jewish americans
are one of the most consistently
liberal voting groups they
overwhelmingly voted for hillary clinton
by even more overwhelming numbers based
on early exit polls
jewish americans voted for joe biden but
that doesn't mean
george soros and quote people like him
are financing imaginary voter fraud
but they always go to some group of jews
to tie the theory together now newt
claims there's voter fraud evidence
there isn't he claims states were stolen
they weren't he claims biden stole the
presidency
he didn't but then in pops that what
weaves it all together
is a jewish man put up the money to do
this and i actually
fear that mentioning that makes the
whole thing more credible
to some of these right-wing nuts i i
worry that he's putting it in there
because it probably helps
it's actually irresponsible to continue
putting newt gingrich on the air and fox
news is going to have to figure out
what is their play going to be for the
next few months but the message for
us as we see this and we i'm going to
have videos later today
of mitt romney and john kasich which
will stun you or maybe they won't
what we have to understand is these are
awful people and they're not going away
democrats can't go soft the left can't
go soft thinking whoa
now that trump was such a disaster in
biden one
we'll be able to work productively with
republicans
no no the election was funded
by people who donated to joe biden i
think it was like 37
each and it is mostly people on the left
the rare anti-trump republicans or
anti-trump republican groups
these are not our friends gingrich is
not our friend
he was not anti-trump by the way and we
are going to talk about that because
there's a certain naivete
about bipartisanship that's spreading
and guys it's not going anywhere
but as far as george soros goes he's i
think he's 90 years old
the idea that george soros is financing
the theft of individual ballots like a
ground game of stealing a few thousand
ballots here and there to steal states
give me a break guys it's just another
anti-semitic conspiracy theory and
after the break we will talk about these
anti-trump republicans are not our
friends more on that coming up